like guys can cheat and still love you
i'd rather they didn't yeah
but you know but you're good
what it's like no this is that's it okay
in a girl's head this is inconceivable
okay this is like
how about how dare you yeah
but i've talked to guys okay
and they tell me they're like look at it
she was just there
like it was just better than my hand for
the night it was it's like a handshake
to them sometimes
sex
and as a girl were like
what like i could never do that but like
to guys it's just
literally easy like i've been in that
situation um
it wasn't great eventually i stopped i
was like i can't do it because i thought
about myself i wouldn't
want to be like if i was that girl i
wouldn't be in that situation i wouldn't
be like cheated on um
but yeah they take if they have that
opportunity they will take it no
hesitation whatsoever no matter the age
bear in mind this guy was
he was way older than me he was i think
25
and now i'm way older
yeah would you
would you
do everything that i just mentioned and
he doesn't cheat would you would you
essentially stay with him but he's not
he doesn't have no escorts no nothing
yeah
okay so now
thinking now no but maybe of course
no no i'm talking not not not the guy
that you're talking about
the situation i explained the high
volume in yeah so you wouldn't you
wouldn't stay with him even if you had
kids maybe now i'll say no now because
i'm like i'm still not at that stage yet
okay
i think as you grow as paul said
your like mentality changes and then
you're just they're like
no
i it's time to have like a family and
don't you know if you're ugly or not
like i'll i'll take the help yeah if
that was in the future if i got that
that and i would literally build a
foundation for myself
and then scroll for that like
as long as i'm fine in the future then
like
do whatever yeah so you think that would
be you losing say you're staying with
him while he's having fun with other
people
it's almost to me looking like you're
really there and the only thing he's
given you
that he's been given those girls that he
haven't is money
and that he loves you
because he's given them sex and
enjoyment and all these stuff he's given
you the same thing
so do you think that's a bit of
self-respect
partially like i i personally like i i
couldn't sign up for that right yeah but
the point is there's a group of people
that do
and the reason why is because they get
the legacy they get their name on the
deed they get the life insurance they
get the last name they get the kids they
get they get him at home they get
and to them if they're like you know if
i get to live this lifestyle if i get
the man of my dreams if he has every
single thing i want i'll just put up
with it i don't like it but if there's
no stds no one ever finds out there's no
outside babies he's not in love with her
who cares
that's that's just the mentality i i
personally i think maybe we grew up kind
of similar like my parents were together
they didn't they didn't do that yeah but
but it's just interesting because it's
just a lifestyle for a certain group
yeah yeah and it's not and it's not
really cheating because
he lets them know yeah it's exploring
their options because one thing i've
learned and it still blows my mind today
a high value man has
umpteen options yeah and so if you're
his main he still
has those he still has the ability to
go out and cheat why not let you know up
front hey this is what i'm gonna do
because it's in my nature to want to do
this but you're
you're my number one you're my main i
love you i don't love these girls
because
men can have sex and not be attached to
uh women at all so they just like pearl
said they just see it as a handshake so
wouldn't you rather have him tell you
straight up what's gonna happen
instead of
he's gonna cheat regardless because
or explore his options regardless
because he is of high value and he has
the means to be able to do that
so when you want to be told up front
that is happening and be able to sit
back chill i'll get 30k a month my man
still come home to me
i'll take it no i i really won't but
well i think
because of how society has you know been
advanced how it has just grown
i think now most women would
go through with it because
almost like money is literally
everything at this point so they would
take that money and invest in that money
and have him there like it's literally
their sugar daddy yeah
wow he can do what he wants as long as
they're getting money and they're
enjoying their life but the question of
the hour is
because you can love this guy and come
to an agreement how would you feel if he
actually ended up having kids with other
women while he's with you yeah i mean
that's usually the
the line right that's why a lot of these
guys use escorts because
these girls are literally like paid to
be clean and not get pregnant like that
like they're paid thousands like
hundreds of thousands of like this is
their job right
um but no i think most girls like
that that's the line
that's over the
that's outside of the agreement and it's
interesting because as much as i want to
say like
like i mean these guys ha like tiger
woods
he remember the cheating scandal way
back when yeah and everyone was judging
him and for good reason he had a lot of
hoes oh my god i heard there's like
facebook groups with all of them
yeah yeah wow
yeah oh my gosh reckless and um but
someone said you don't know what it's
like to get to like
to get off like the the what do they
call it the field the green the green
two uh
18
uh was it like 18 something woman yeah
like eight like brazilian models yeah
all dying to sleep with you with no
strengths attached yo that's like that's
hard for any guy yeah
i don't care who you are you could be
the guy that has the most self-control
he's still gonna be hard for you growing
at you like please like that's
fighting over who gets to like be with
him that night
and it's a super this is it most guys
will never experience oh yeah
just like most girls won't ever
experience having high value men fight
over them yeah
this is the live this is the one maybe
one day pearl if we keep in this in this
sphere maybe one day bro we're past wall
i'm not past the wall yet i'm not
passing yet like are we peaked at like
22 apparently 20 30. no first i
personally and people may say
they will arrest you yeah but i
i think that now
i
i think i look better now than when i
did in high school okay
i
rarely look the same but i think that
just
how i
kind of like how i carry myself that was
very like we talked i was very tomboy in
high school so it was just like a i look
like a dude or a lesbian and a lot of
people thought i was a lesbian you're a
lesbian yeah i would i would play you
were that far in the time
i didn't i didn't look i just was like
very very tomboy and i would play that
joke on people i'd be like yeah i'm a
lesbian people would believe it because
i was a tomboy i've gotten that one
yeah and so i think
now i think i look better now than in
high school i know people i'm like
that's cat but if you saw me in high
school
you'd probably agree
oh they said 24 was a woman's peak hey
they said i look 24 so
i'm right there so cool you can't
the comment section's funny i
gotta love them
reverse ageism that's what i'm doing
benjamin button up in here
um
but yeah i don't know it's a very small
percentage of society that does this but
it's interesting because it kind of
shows people's true natures like
what happens when a guy gets all the
money and power in the world and what
what happens when a girl gets all the
beauty in the world and the youth who
who do they pick each other
but then you also see hollywood where
they also have terrible relationships
like that's kind of a combination of the
most beautiful women and the
maybe not i wouldn't say most powerful
men but like at least they have status
and stuff yeah yeah i would say their
status is higher than most because there
are a lot of
excuse me there's a lot of powerful men
that nobody knows about there's so many
like i would say undercover like
billionaires that nobody knows about
because they're just
they just they're in the top one percent
right and they just go to work go home
and they just chill with their family
yeah
and nobody knows about them because
they're not in like mainstream what have
you guys talked about so far what red
pill um
i asked him about feminism but we didn't
dive deep into it okay
um
so
did you guys know the pay gap isn't real
the the pay gap
i didn't mention when that is the
difference between like
uh women's wages and men wages how they
say women get paid less than men oh that
pay again yeah yeah they get all the cap
though yeah you think it's all cap you
think it's real it's true okay women get
paid less than men yes
how comes what you do of course
yeah so it's interesting i used to
actually think that too
but it's interesting because if you take
into account
the jobs that women work
so women tend to pick careers that make
less money and they tend to work less
hours so if me and you we're gonna work
a job and i worked eight hours for a
year and he works 10 hours for a year
he's going to beat me by the end of the
year
and it's interesting because let me find
this um
men are more
i want to say 17 times more likely to
die in the workplace
so it's like oh they're picking like you
get paid more if you might die
oh
no i'm serious who wants to do like yeah
women don't want to take that risk i'm
not like if you if you made okay if you
made six figures you would work an oil
rig would you do it
um
sorry i'm not speaking in english
no you would not they know you speak
english
she does
oh i do
she just didn't want to answer it i was
like i thought you're american no she's
not she's a colombian oh oh well i'm
venezuelan sorry i always get i don't
know why i get that
venezuelan sorry lo siento they're right
next to each other no venezuelan she's
from america oh 23. men are 23 more
times more likely to die in the
workplace than women oh yeah that's mad
yeah go ahead you know when it comes to
the wages and stuff and the difference
people only say that now that the men
get paid more than women i mean again
history has changed and
they're mostly sticking to what's been
you know it's been that way in the past
where
women have to get paid less or women are
not supposed to work and the men are
supposed to so i guess that's just
driving straight through
till today for men to be working as hard
as they are and i mean men love money as
well as they love women so they rather
work to get money
and women come on
money get women